There are some verses in the Quran that
specifically talks about the woman.
Allah says in the Quran in surah chapter
4 verse number one, respect the womb
that bore you. Respecting the mother.
The Quran says in surahman 31 verse
number 14, we have enjoined on the human
beings to be kind to the parents. In
travel upon travel did the m mother b
them and in years twain was the weaning
here specifically the mother is singled
out after respecting the parents. Allah
repeats the message in surah hak chapter
43 verse number 15. We have enjoined on
the human beings to be kind to the
parents. In pain did the mother bore
them and in pain did she give them
birth.
Quran says respect the parents
in surah anam chapter 6 verse number 151
and surah Isra chapter number 17 verse
number 31. There are various verses
in which the Quran says respect your
parents and then specifies specifically
your mother.
There's a hadith of the prophet sallall
alaihi wasallam
which says that paradise lies beneath
the feet of your mother. It's a say
hadith of sun had number 3106 where the
prophet said paradise lies beneath the
feet of your mother. That does not mean
if my mother is walking on the street
and if she steps on filth and muck that
becomes paradise. What the prophet meant
that if
if you serve your mother, you respect
her, you obey her and take care of her,
inshallah you shall enter paradise.
There's a hadith in Sai Bkari had number
5,972.
A man approached the prophet and asked
him
that who deserves the maximum love and
companionship in this world. The prophet
said your mother. The man asked after
that who? The prophet said your mother.
The man ASKED AFTER THAT WHO? THE
PROPHET said your mother. THE MAN ASKED
AFTER THAT WHO? THEN THE PROPHET said
your father. That means 3/4
75%
of the love and companionship goes to
your mother. and 25% goes to the father.
That means as far as love and
companionship to your parents is
concerned, the mother gets the gold
medal, she gets the silver medal, she
also gets the bronze medal. The father
has to be satisfied with the mere
consolation prize.
These are the teachings of Islam. our
beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. This is what I call true
and practical gender equality.
Here the prophet didn't say man woman
equal both get gold medal man woman
equal both get silver. No, no, no.
Because the prophet said, "Even if you
give her what your mother bears you in
her womb for 9 months,
even if you give the mountain of gold,
you cannot compensate.
You cannot.
So equality does not mean identicality.
Depending upon the physiological makeup,
the biological makeup, the psychological
makeup,
the roles and duties differ.